totgesagte leben länger zum beispiel die
kohle gilt aber auch für erdgas das
ebenfalls schon auf der streichliste der
klimaschutzpolitik stand ohne große
mengen dieser beiden energieträger
dürften im winter die wohnungen ziemlich
kalt bleiben und die wirtschafts hintern
vor dem kollaps und immer wieder kommt
die frage auf ob eine
laufzeitverlängerung von kernkraftwerken
ist das erneuerbare energie sicherheit
nachhaltig die regie in der versorgung
übernehmen kann das wird knapp wie
kommen wir durch den winter jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
snacks zugeschaltet ist professor hans
werner sinn ökonomen und ehemaliger
präsident des ifo instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung im studio begrüße
ich lisa warum sie sind obfrau von
bündnis 90 die grünen im bundestag und
obfrau im ausschuss für klima und
energie für die cdu sitzt gedacht konnte
man im bundestag und sie sind außerdem
bundesvorsitzende der mittelstands- und
wirtschaftskrise sich sascha renner ist
bundesgeschäftsführer
der deutschen umwelthilfe frau bat um
kohlekraftwerke ans netz bringen um die
versorgung zu sichern und dabei
klimaschützer beschwichtigen müssen das
könnte ihre partei in eine krise stürzen
ja ja wir sind insgesamt in europa in
einer krise wir erleben einen
angriffskrieg und die situation ist
ziemlich ernst putin hat jetzt auch
einen gas krieg gegen uns begonnen hat
die mengen stark gedrosselt und das ist
die sehr ernste situation in der wir
sind gleichzeitig müssen wir für einen
warmen winter vorsorgen und so kommt es
eben zustande dass wir wohl auch
gezwungen sein werden müssen mehr kohle
zu verfolgen als in diesem jahr wollten
das ist sehr schmerzhaft für mich das
können sie mir natürlich glauben aber
wir können in so einer situation in so
einer krise natürlich auch nicht auch
einfach weitermachen wie bisher die
große frage ist wollen wir langfristig
weiter auf dem pfad bleiben und unsere
klimaziele erfüllen und erst recht
erneuerbare schneller ausbauen
energiesparen stärker forcieren das ist
die entscheidende frage und da setzt
natürlich dafür ein und wie das gelingt
wollen wir in der sendung auch
besprechen frau konnte man die union ist
aus der regierungsverantwortung heraus
und in der opposition gelandet jetzt
gibt es aber kritik an ihnen und ihrer
partei hätte man in der groko mehr für
erneuerbare energien getan also für die
weiterentwicklung für den aufbau von
erneuerbarer energien dann stünden wir
heute besser da was sagen sie diesen
vorwurf der vorwurf ist nicht berechtigt
denn wir haben heute schon einen anteil
an erneuerbaren energien von 40 prozent
das ist eine menge es könnte mehr sein
ohne frage es gibt viele gründe weswegen
es auch vor ort hakt das beginnt mit
planungsprobleme mit kompensations
problemen und vielem mehr aber fakt ist
dass ein grundproblem der erneuerbaren
nicht gelöst worden ist das ist die
speicherfähigkeit denn am ende wird die
sonne nicht immer scheint der wind nicht
immer wenn das heißt jeder energiewende
lag zugrunde das ist eine
brückentechnologie geben muss diese
brückentechnologie vargas wir sind alle
davon ausgegangen dass gas verfügbar ist
und bezahlbar und das stellt sich jetzt
eben im moment als ihr glaube heraus vor
dem hintergrund dass putin tatsächlich
jetzt uns einen krieg erklärt hat indem
er dieses gas als waffe einsetzt und wir
merken es aktuell durch die drosselung
der gaslieferungen droht eine gasmenge
lage das heißt wir müssen antworten
finden wie in zwölf wochen im winter
geheizt werden kann und das wird
übrigens nicht gehen dem grunde nach
auch mit alleine erneuerbaren energien
sondern die frage wird beantwortet
werden müssen woher bekommen wir welche
am ende auch fossile energie um diese
brückentechnologie zu ersetzen und diese
fragen wird derzeit nicht beantworten
und die müssen wir aber ja beantworten
hat müller keller hätte wäre wenn das
hilft jetzt auch relativ wenig weiter
die klima und umweltschützer die werden
ja dicke kröten schlucken müssen um
deutschlands energieabhängigkeit von
russland zu reduzieren
erhalten sie es noch für denkbar dass da
die dicke kröte mit dabei ist die
befristete weiterführung von
kernkraftwerken
naja erstmal hat natürlich jetzt dieser
schreckliche krieg uns allen gezeigt
dass für eine fatale abhängigkeit wir
uns von fossilen energieimporten begeben
haben das gilt ja nicht nur für gas das
gilt auch für öl das gilt für kohle es
gilt auch nicht nur für russland sondern
auch für andere länder sollten übrigens
auch aufpassen dass man in zukunft so
sich nicht in abhängigkeiten von anderen
lieferanten begibt
der lupenreine demokratie charta zum
beispiel das vielleicht mal so auch als
einstiegsdiesel natürlich wäre
sinnvoller gewesen sehr viel stärker
noch als bisher auf erneuerbare energien
zu setzen jetzt ist es natürlich so wir
müssen sich den nächsten winter kommen
dann mache ich mir genau so sorgen die
ganz ganz viele menschen in diesem land
und natürlich müssen wir da auch ein
paar entscheidungen treffen die sind
schwierig das heißt zum beispiel dass
müssen kohlekraftwerke vorübergehend
wieder ans netz trotzdem müssen wir
natürlich darauf achten dass es beim
kohleausstieg bleibt aus
klimaschutzgründen wir haben uns ja im
klimaschutz viel vorgenommen wir müssen
natürlich auch schauen wie wir diesen
wegfall mit dem wir rechnen müssen des
russischen gases zumindest teilweise
kompensieren aber natürlich müssen wir
zuallererst anfang jetzt mal energie zu
sparen öl einzusparen gas einzusparen da
fehlen mir wirklich die vorschläge und
stattdessen werden halt immer so die
alten
klamotten aus der mottenkiste geholt
atomkraft fracking und diese geschichten
sind ja alles keine realistische
aussicht auf möglicherweise gleich eine
inhaltsangabe der sendung mitgelieferten
darüber werden wir reden als erstes über
die fragen was passiert jetzt mit den
oder volvo zu oder wie lange werden
diese fossilen energieträger benötigt
dann über sparen und dann auch die frage
wie schnell die erneuerbaren energien
uns da abhilfe schaffen können herr sind
selbst die reaktorbetreiber lehnen ja
eine längere laufzeit von
atomkraftwerken ab heute haben ja so
wohl fühlt sich merz als auch christian
linden auf dem tag der deutschen
industrie noch einmal betont es müssen
diese drei noch am netz befindlichen
atomkraftwerke weitergeführt oder
sollten weitergeführt werden zumindest
sollte man das überprüfen aber wenn die
reaktorbetreiber doch schon nicht wollen
führen wir dann hier eine
phantomdiskussion
die reaktorbetreiber haben sich
eingerichtet auf den neuen
regulierungsrahmen und wurden ja bezahlt
für den ausstieg die können gewinne mit
allen machen es geht aber um
gesamtwirtschaftliche vorteile und
sicherheit und die atomkraft ist eine
energie die uns ein bisschen autark
macht denn die vorräte an brennstoffen
kann man ja für jahre im voraus kaufen
auch die kohle macht uns autark und
gerade diese beiden fossilen
energieträger haben wir jetzt abgestellt
oder wollen sie abstellen und wollen
aufs gas weil das gas die nötige
regelenergie ist die komplementär zur
grünen
flatterhaften wind und wetter abhängigen
energie hier zur verfügung steht und
oder stehen soll und die ist eben jetzt
nicht mehr da damit haben wir einen
scherbenhaufen dieses energiepolitischen
kurs in deutschland erlebt gut es ist
jetzt nicht die frage wie wir mit der
situation des energiemix auch
zurechtkommen ich würde ganz gerne ganz
kurz und zur kernenergie etwas fragen
einer der hauptlieferanten für
brennstäbe die müssen ja dann wenn man
das weiterführt müssten die brennstäbe
irgendwann mal erneuert werden dass
ausgerechnet russland das klingt fast
wie ein schildbürgerstreich wenn man die
atomkraft weiter führt und dann wieder
von russland abhängig ist fakt ist dass
es am ende um die frage geht wer kann
uran liefern und bei uran ist es so dass
russland nur 2,9 prozent des urans
liefert das weltweit benötigt wird wir
haben ganz große lieferanten zb mit
kasachstan kanada etc pp und zur
wahrheit gehört werden über 400
kernkraftwerke auf der welt wir wollen
drei weiter betreiben und alle anderen
haben kein problem
uran zu bekommen dann wird es für diese
drei in deutschland auch reichen
ein haken also das klingt natürlich
immer sehr einfach die atomenergie als
silver bullet und es wundert mich auch
nicht immer sind sie vertreten seit
jahren diese these dass sie jetzt
natürlich das sagen was sie immer gesagt
haben dass die energiewende nicht
funktioniert und wie auf atomkraft
setzen sollen aber darauf wird nicht
richtiger und man muss auch wirklich
unterscheiden zwischen natürlichem uran
angereichertem uran und brennstäben und
die das angereicherte uran ist zb in
australien und kanada was ja häufig
angeführt wird dann eben nicht so
vorhanden wir haben eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung im jahr 2019
gehabt wir hatten in letzter zeit keine
ja wir müssen das alles noch mal
komplett neu aufsetzen wir haben gar
keine ingenieure mehr die sich in den
lkws auskennen also diese ganzen themen
sind ja geprüft wurden von den
ministerien und es wird uns kurzfristig
nicht helfen und auch kurzfristig nicht
möglich sein aber das muss man einfach
zur kenntnis nehmen es ist eine
ablenkung debatte ich kenne das aus
bayern wo man sich mit nicht mit
windkraft abständen befassen will und
dann immer auf die atomenergie verweist
es ist sehr schön einfach aber die
wahrheit und realität ist etwas
komplexer und das ist der aus einer
deshalb eine geht in dieser sendung
nichts weder die abstände von
windkraftanlagen noch die frage der
kernenergie bereich das jetzt nicht mehr
so lange wir sprechen würde war das was
jetzt gesagt haben dass die
ideologiefreie prüfung von ihrem
parteifreund robert habeck was den
weiterbetrieb der kernenergie angeht
genau es gab eine prüfung von
umweltministerium und
wirtschaftsministerium wo genau diese
punkte noch mal abgeklopft wurden und
die konzern betreiber ist es gesagt
worden möchten es selber nicht machen
weil sie sagen es würde viel viel mehr
kosten dass sie zweiter zu betreiben
abgesehen von den technischen hürden und
das muss man einfach mal zur kenntnis
nehmen ich weiß es ist spannend die
sauna wieder durchs dorf zu treiben wir
hatten schon mal ein ausstieg aus dem
ausstieg mit der cdu und das ist aber
nicht der weg da muss man wirklich
verantwortung übernehmen jetzt es geht
nicht um eine sau durchs dorf treiben
sondern bin einigermaßen hat das geben
was es ja wir brauchen aktuell wie ich
jede kilowattstunde
und wir haben mit drei bestehenden
kernkraftwerken die möglichkeit
weiterhin strom zu erzeugen
die
ideologiefreie prüfung die angedeutet
worden ist das papier nicht mehr auf das
wert auf dem sie steht und zur wahrheit
gehört eines sie sagen auf der einen
seite wir wollen kernenergieerzeugung in
deutschland beenden aber sie haben
überhaupt kein problem damit dass viele
kernenergienutzung nach wie vor
fortführen denn wir bekommen jeden tag
atomstrom aus frankreich aus den
niederlanden aus tschechien und so
weiter und deshalb würde ich empfehlen
sich tatsächlich offen mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen hier wollt sollte
nicht sein was nicht sein darf sowohl
die betreiber sagen wir haben personal
das zur verfügung gestellt werden könnte
jemand wie herr maas der mitglied der
reaktorsicherheitskommission
war sagt ist es überhaupt kein problem
die sicherheitsüberprüfung auch im
laufenden betrieb durchzuführen und bei
den brennstäben ist es so man kann im
gestreckten betrieb einen teil der
brennstäbe natürlich weiter verwenden
das ist kein problem entscheidend ist
dass die betreiber ein signal seitens
der politik benötigen und dieses signal
ist bislang nicht gekommen aber jetzt
wird es tatsächlich gibt ein point of no
return
und was die betreiber nicht machen
werden ist dass sie ein risiko alleine
schultern der professor sinn hat es
gesagt insoweit brauchen wir auch
zusagen der politik und ich kann nur
sagen in zwölf wochen beginnt die
heizperiode und der sehr dass diese und
werden diese lückenlose
vernehmungen stehen diese lücke werden
das nicht zu energiesicherheit sowie
brillen maskat gesagt es ist in einer
solchen situation energie eigentlich
weiß nicht ob ich das wenn ich laut
aussprechen darf ihnen macht sehen sie
sicherlich immer als visionär auch rand
voranstellen hat gesagt wir müssen
verrückt sein jetzt die kernkraftwerke
abzustellen und bitte bei aller
ideologie auf ihrer seite bitte keine
verrücktheiten mehr sondern jede
kilowattstunde nutzt also wir
diskutieren gerade über das thema erst
ganz kurz glauben sie dass die kernkraft
wirklich weiterlaufen wird oder ist das
der diskussion die am jahresende zu ende
ist egal was bis dahin passiert wird
ja das hängt davon ab ob putin das gas
wirklich abstellt wenn es dann eng wird
dann werden die grünen über ihren
schatten springen und ich glaube herr
beck ist derjenige der das der das
machen kann
es ist einfach auch richtig
dann wenn ich das schon früher gesagt
habe wird es ja nicht falsch dadurch
dass es jetzt festgestellt wird der
beschluss von 2011 war einfach falsch
das war ein spontaner beschluss der
kanzlerin die das thema abräumen wollte
wie sie das ja immer so tut mit ihrer
asymetrischen demobilisierung oder tat
um die wahl in baden württemberg zu
gewinnen hat mich ganz funktioniert die
grünen kamen dann trotzdem hoch so kann
man keine energiepolitik machen
deutschland ist das einzige land auf der
erde das aus der atomkraft aussteigt wir
sind wirklich der geisterfahrer auf der
autobahn
die japaner sind wieder dabei die
schweizer sind wieder dabei die die
schwedin die als erste ausstiegen nach
dem unglück von harrisburg
1979 haben lange beschlossen im jahr
2016 nämlich
parteiübergreifend dass sie ihre
atomkraftwerke behalten und reparieren
und auf diese energieform setzen und die
eu hat inzwischen gesagt das ist eine
grüne energie ist ruh schmach für die
deutschen ja die grünen waren jetzt ganz
still bei dem thema aber es ist nun mal
so die beschlüsse sind gefallen und die
ganzen fördermaßnahmen die der
ausgedacht wurden insbesondere auch die
taxonomie verordnung der eu die politik
der europäischen zentralbank die grüne
wertpapiere besonders günstig behandelt
so dass ich ein zins differenzial
herausbildet dass die sich billiger
finanzieren können das alles läuft auf
kernenergie hin aus und machen wir uns
nichts vor auch der schöne grüne
wasserstoff von dem viele zu recht
träumen und hoch hohe erwartungen haben
der wird aber nicht aus australien von
irgendwelchen windfarmen oder
solarpaneelen kommen sondern der wird
direkt von den französischen
atomkraftwerken nach deutschland
geliefert und ist grün und nichts was
wir tun und nichts was in unserer macht
steht kann das behindert denn das ist ja
eu-recht das gilt als grün und wir
dürfen keine handelsschranken innerhalb
der eu errichten das heißt es kommt
immer mehr französische atomstrom nach
deutschland und sicherer werden wir
dadurch auch nicht wahr wenn es mal eine
havarie gibt ja dann bläst der westwind
den ganzen fond laut nach deutschland
also es hat so überhaupt keinen sinn
wird ich würde jetzt war die ein
energiemix haben und das problem ja auch
ist die wir jetzt diesen energiemangel
überbrücken das ist das was die menschen
am meisten eher interessiert hat mir da
keiner gebrauchen strom wir brauchen
energie
wie lange soll denn der kohlestrom das
ist ja der andere energie steuer der
strom liefert neben der atomkraft uns
denn bei der stromerzeugung noch bei
stehen damit genügend gas frei wird für
die erzeugung von wärmeenergie und vor
allem auch für die industrie was glauben
sie wie lange das sein wird und was
bedeutet das natürlich dann vor allen
dingen auch für das klima wenn ihr jetzt
relativ lange auf kohle strom angewiesen
sind sie haben jetzt das stichwort schon
genannt es die menschen machen sich
momentan darüber sorgen dass sie im
winter nicht heizen können oder
zumindest nicht zu bezahlbaren preisen
heizen können und die deutsche industrie
macht sich natürlich zu recht sorge dass
die kapazitäten stilllegen muss und weil
die energie nicht mehr zur verfügung
steht oder nicht zu bezahlbaren preisen
und das hat in der regel nicht mit strom
zu tun so mit wärme und das ist ja das
problem dadurch dass die gasimporte
wegfallen oder erheblich reduziert
werden wir haben keinen strom problem
wir haben im wesentlichen in wärme
problem und da brauchen wir die lösung
die kurzfristige lösung ist der wirklich
energie einsparen da hat jetzt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister an guten
vorschlag gemacht dass er gesagt hat für
die industrie das ist ein system gibt
dass
wärme kapazitäten das gas kapazitäten
auktioniert werden also dass in der
wirtschaft selbst geschaut werden kann
wo gibt es potenziale einzusparen es
gibt sicher auch sinnvolle vorschläge
für private haushalte also man kann sich
natürlich jetzt auch beraten lassen wie
man die heizung besser ein stellt diese
dinge aber das große potenzial das ist
in der industrie und dass wir dann für
die überbrückung für die überbrückung
dieser krise
ein paar kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve
und die sind hier aus guten gründen in
der reserve wieder rein nehmen müssen
das ist klar aber dazu haben wir dann
den europäischen emissionshandel der
jetzt zum glück auch noch einmal
weiterentwickelt wird dass wir dann eben
auch eine deckelung haben der
gesamtemissionen das heißt jetzt mehr
coole aber dann muss man natürlich auf
das jahr 2030 hin dann schneller aus der
kohle raus weil eins ist klar der
klimaschutz darf jetzt hier nicht über
die wupper springen und über die klinge
springen wir müssen unsere klimaziele
erreichen weil das sehen wir ja auch
wenn wir abends nachrichten schauen dann
sehen wir ja nicht nur was in der
ukraine passiert sondern wir sehen auch
die brennenden wälder in brandenburg die
klimakrise die ist hier und das ist auf
keinen fall verhandelbar jetzt zu sagen
die klimakrise muss jetzt den schritt
zur seite drehen und warten sondern
natürlich müssen der energiesicherheit
und klimaschutz verbinden das ist der
ist natürlich mit dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie verbunden obwohl
ich gleich mal extra ja gesagt
erneuerbare energien sind freiheits
energien das war ein sehr sehr wichtiger
satz in der bundestagsdebatte zum
ukraine krieg und das unterschreibe ich
völlig ich hätte gewünscht mir wäre
dieser slogan eingefahren das ist
richtig nur mit erneuerbaren sind wir
letztendlich die meine sicherheit aber
da muss man natürlich auch was tun bei
der stromerzeugung soll jetzt quasi gas
gespart werden und dafür wird jetzt
kohle wieder eingesetzt die
kohlekraftwerke werden in diesen
reserven mottos gestellt und jederzeit
ans netz gehen können weil eben gas vor
allen dingen für die wärmeenergie
gebraucht wird kriegen überhaupt
genügend gas ins land wir haben ja
speicherkapazitäten moment von 56
prozent ist es gott sei dank ich war mal
sommer aber das wird nicht ewig zu sein
und moment sieht's mit den
gaslieferungen air mouse wir kratzen aus
allen richtungen gas zusammen ich würde
gerne einen schritt zurückgehen weil ich
sehr wichtig finde was was gesagt wurde
wir müssen einfach sehen dass wir in
dieser krisensituation sind hohe preise
fossil flaschen und dass wir keine
versorgungssicherheit haben durch unsere
große abhängigkeit von fossilen energien
übrigens auch von uran aus russland her
sind aber auch kohle öl und gas das
heißt es falsch sei wäre es jetzt
langfristig aus der krise zu gehen mit
den vorschlägen die uns rein geführt
haben das ist das was mich an diesen
themen stört jetzt wieder aus der
mottenkiste rausgekramt werden wir sind
wir haben nicht eine
versorgungssicherheit wir legen wegen
erneuerbaren strom mehr sind sondern wir
haben eine versorgungs unsicherheit
wegen uns auf fossilen abhängigkeit das
muss man hier kann man wirklich nicht
oft genug sein deswegen müssen die
lösungsmöglichkeiten jetzt seien daran
arbeiten wir wir arbeiten an eine reform
des erneuerbare-energien-gesetzes
aktuell im moment und die bürgerinnen
bürger zu befragen und die unternehmen
erneuerbaren strom direkt vor ort zu
erzeugen und sich selbst versorgen zu
können und es gibt studien dass
beispielsweise auch die stadtwerke viele
von gas weg umstellen können auch
richtung abwärme richtung hackschnitzel
und ähnliches geothermie stadtwerke
münchen die werden ihr siebtes
geothermie kraftwerk bauen wir haben ja
die optionen aber deswegen finde ich es
richtig dass wir über die zukunftsoption
reden die jetzt da sind ja auch in lienz
library monaten wenn unabhängig machen
die winter die herbst und wintersaison
beginnt ist schon so weit sind die frage
ist genau deswegen haben wir uns zu
dieser schmerzhaften sache durchgerungen
weil wir wollen dass die speicher und
das ist übrigens wahnsinn was wir alles
für gesetzespaket auf den weg gebracht
haben ist die letzten paar jahre nichts
passiert der letzten regierung und haben
in wenigen wochen wir haben zehn
gesetzte im energie- und klimabereich
gerne dass energie sicherungs gesetz
wieder aktualisiert was von der ölkrise
74 war wir haben ein gasspeicher gesetz
verabschiedet wo drinsteht 90 prozent
wollen wir im november sein müssen wir
die gasspeicher voll machen und das ist
genau das was jemand gehen wir haben
wir müssen gas speicher voll machen wir
müssen sparen da ja auch eher wichtig
komme ich gleich dazu hilft auch nicht
jetzt zurück zu blicken es gibt wir sind
nicht die einzigen gas einkäufer der
welt es geht ja nicht nur um katar es
geht auch um flüssiggas importe es geht
um andere lieferländer andere sind da ja
auch mit im spiel die brauchen auch gas
viele haben sich von gas abhängig
gemacht auch von russischem gas nicht
nur deutschland
wie soll das eigentlich werten wenn sich
so viele um das gas schlagen die preise
die werden ja in astronomische höhen
steigen zum herbst hin weil ja jeder
seine gasspeicher voll machen will nicht
nur deutschland absolut richtig wir
haben nicht nur ein mengenproblem
sondern werden einen preis problem wenn
putins zurzeit 60 prozent drosselt und
wir wissen nicht was nach dem 11 juli
passiert wenn der große inventur der von
nord stream 1 erfolgt ob sie nach zehn
tagen überhaupt wieder angeschmissen
wird dann haben wir jetzt den fakt dass
uns zurzeit die ladung von einem lng
schiff pro tag fehlt also dem grunde
nach zu flüssig genau flüssigkeit 1000
gigawatt wir haben
von daher nochmal ein mengenproblem auf
der einen seite aber eben ein preis
problem auf der anderen seite der preis
für einen kubikmeter gas hat sich
versechsfacht darüber reden wir und das
heißt dass wir zurzeit probleme haben
auch mit gasimporteuren die durch
verträge auch günstigere verträge
gebunden sind die jetzt tatsächlich auch
in finanzielle zwangslage kommen sodass
wir gegebenenfalls irgendwann an einen
punkt sein werden wo tatsächlich im
rahmen einer gas
gast notlage dann diese preis auch
umgewälzt werden an verbraucher aber
eben auch entsprechend an die wirtschaft
und das heißt wir haben hier in dreieck
versorgungssicherheit klimaschutz und
preissicherheit und das dilemma ist weit
über klimaschutz gesprochen worden ist
ich finde es eine verhöhnung zu sagen
sie treten für den klimaschutz ein aber
sie aktivieren kohlekraftwerke und
wollen kernkraftwerke nicht weiterlaufen
dass man kann kernkraft vieles
absprechen aber sie co2 neutral sie
schützt das klima und in dieser
situation aus ideologischen gründen
heraus zu sagen wir wollen es nicht weil
wir als grüne nicht bereit sind alles
auf das tableau zu stellen das finde ich
unfair ich würde gerne aber dieser mann
und ich würde darauf wieder noch mal
zurückkommen würde mich dass ich jetzt
sagen die preise für verbraucher für
unternehmen sind zudem unter nehmen was
bedeutet das für die wirtschaft wenn die
energiepreise jetzt durch die decke
gehen was vermuten sie was befürchten
sie
naja also die wirtschaft besteht einmal
aus den firmen die meinen sie wohl die
haben dann schwierigkeiten bestimmte
produktionsprozesse zu realisieren wo
eben sehr viel energie rein geht und man
kann hier bei einem embargo der russen
rechnen damit ist das sozialprodukt um
um 4 prozent um vielleicht mehr 8
prozent fällt es gibt da verschiedene
schätzung aber die wirtschaft besteht ja
nun auch vor allem aus den menschen
nicht und die sind ja betroffen jenseits
des sozialprodukts indem sie eben
heizenergie nicht mehr haben 48 prozent
der deutschen heizen mit gas wenn die
gasvorräte nicht zur verfügung stehen
dann müssen die frieren es sei denn man
rationiert nur die firmen dann wird es
da um so schlimmer aber es ist ein
riesenproblem für deutschland dass so
abhängig geworden ist und hört ja bitte
nochmal eins sagen dürfen ist ein
bisschen schwierig wenn ich nicht im
studio sitze direkt zu reagieren aber
die vorstellung die grüne energie würde
uns jetzt besonders
unabhängig machen und sicherheit
schaffen also die halte ich nicht für
richtig bin sehr für grüne energie wird
das war ganz klar sagen das ist schon
richtig wir müssen etwas gegen
klimawandel uns weiter tun aber man muss
die argumente auch korrekt halten die
grüne energie ist extrem volatil der
wind weht nicht immer und die sonne
scheint nicht immer und manchmal haben
wir dunkel flotten und ist gar nichts
dran dann müssen konventionelle energien
für die gesamte stromversorgung da sein
und bei den konventionellen haben wir
entweder kohle oder atom oder gas und
die grünen und auch die deutsche
strategie war so
orientiert dass man auf gas gesetzt hat
war gab es ja auch nur zur hälfte bei
der verbrennung co2 freisetzt im
vergleich zur kohle
jetzt ist aber gerade diese energie weg
viele leute denken ja wenn wir mehr
grüne energien haben dann können wir die
fossilen zurückdrängen das ist ja nicht
der fall die brauchen ja die
regelenergie das heißt wenn wir doppelt
so viel gas suchen zum viel strom
brauchen für die autos weil die
elektrische laufen sollen und für die
wärmepumpen mit denen die häuser geheizt
werden sollen dann brauchen wir auch
letztlich doppelt so viele
konventionelle energien die dann auch
immer die dunkle flotten die lücken
füllen wir wollen also doppelt so viel
gas kraftwerke oder kohlekraftwerke oder
kernkraftwerke wir kommen nicht drum
herum und das waren gerade also die
kernkraftwerke abstellt abstellt und
wieder auf die kohlekraftwerke geht ist
eben eine klimasünder
erster sorte ja und da sind haben sie
eben gerade diese thema sünde begehen
wollen verstehe ich überhaupt nicht es
sind jetzt haben sie doch sozusagen noch
einmal gesagt was vorhin schon
andiskutiert ist der moderator hat hier
die aufgabe gedanken und inhalte zu
ordnen und zu strukturieren damit die
zuschauer wissen um was es geht jetzt
haben wir wie bei einem adventskalender
gleich mehrere zürich und gleichzeitig
ausgemacht wir waren noch bei dem thema
preise
unternehmen ist das eine was bedeutet
das für die wirtschaft das meinen die
ich ja mit den unternehmen der frau bat
um aber viele privathaushalte geraten
eben auch in existenznöte wie viel geld
hat denn der finanzminister noch um in
not geratene menschen zu unterstützen
die die energiepreise halt zum strom
nicht mehr bezahlen können das müssen
die finanzminister selbst fragen es
heute nicht hier aber ich glaube wir
haben gezeigt durch die zwei entlastungs
paket das wir vor allem dort gezählt in
den eigenen vorstellungen was im alter
zu entlasten wo es nötig ist eben mit
der energiepreis pauschale
beispielsweise mit dem zuschuss zur zur
heizung mit dem kinderzuschlag erhöhung
des grundfreibetrags also wirklich dort
wo menschen auch bedürftig sind denn es
sind auch nicht alle bevölkerungsgruppen
gleich betroffen das muss man auch sagen
also alles mit der gießkanne wäre wäre
nicht der weg und vor allem haben wir
zum beispiel auch höhere
lebensmittelpreise und ähnliches
deswegen
haben wir auch gesagt durch diese
energiepreis pauschale um viele
preissteigerungen abzufangen weil es
betrifft nicht nur energie und diese
politik werden natürlich weitermachen
aber langfristig wirklich sichere preise
werden wir ja in der neuen energiewelt
bekommen wo leider einige aus der runde
auch noch nicht angekommen sind wo wir
selber für unsere versorgungssicherheit
einstehen und es ist ja ein gemeinsames
europäisches ziel also europa 40 prozent
erneuerbare energien insgesamt in 2030
erreichen wir wollen der erste
klimaneutrale kontinent sein und
natürlich werden wir dann auch
untereinander im strom handeln übrigens
ist es eher so dass frankreich von uns
strom kaufen muss im sommer wenn die
atomkraftwerke gekühlt werden können ist
extrem teuer auch teilweise sie haben
ein altes alte kraftwerkskette und so da
möchte ich also da bin ich sehr froh
dass wir nicht in der situation sind
muss ich ehrlich sein aber das ist das
was wirklich für die sicherheit der
bürgerinnen bürger ansteht ist dass man
hier im langfristig plant wir haben auch
für den winter deswegen die flüssiggas
terminals vorgesehen weil wir im
vorsorgen wollen aber die strategie muss
langfristig einfach sein dass wir nicht
in 15 ländern sagen in katar wurde mit
unserem geld wurden menschenrechte nicht
geachtet und menschen unterdrückt
sondern dass wir auf dem weg sind dass
wir als europa ein klimaneutraler
kontinent werden dass wir unsere eigene
wirtschaft werde schon vor ort stärken
und vielleicht letzter punkt da die
energiewende letzten jahren eben sehr
stark behindert wurde sie empfehlen in
bayern habe ich bei der windkraft eben
persönlich mitbekommen ist vielen
kommunen die wertschöpfung entzogen
worden diese milliarden ins ausland
geflossen und das müssen jetzt
zurückdrehen ich würde gerne weiter
jetzt gesagt haben flüssiggas ist glaube
ich nicht das lieblingsthema oder nicht
lieblings entwicklung oder das
lieblingsobjekt von energie was die
deutsche umwelthilfe dahin im blick hat
amerikaner sparen ist schon mehrfach
hier angesprochen worden
man wie viel einsparpotenzial ist denn
eigentlich drin bei uns angefangen bei
den privathaushalten dann bei den
unternehmen was ist dann möglich denn
das wäre ja auch ein beitrag zur
energiesicherheit im kommenden winter
also der gasverbrauch ist ja in
deutschland jetzt seit beginn des jahres
schon um fast 20 prozent gesunken und zu
einem ganz ganz großen zahl sind es auch
einsparungen gewesen das sind auch
einsparungen gewesen hände industrie
teilweise auch in privathaushalten und
ich kann mir zum beispiel vorstellen und
die wirtschaftsweise veronika grimm hat
heute vorgeschlagen man sollte doch zum
beispiel mal privathaushalten auch ein
paar prämien geben wenn sie eben bei
sich beim heizen einsparen ich glaube
jetzt nicht dass da irgendwelche
vorschriften jetzt sinnstiftend sind ihr
müsst jetzt eure als temperatur um zwei
prozent senken aber natürlich gibt es
ganz ganz viele leute die sich jetzt
gedanken machen wie man auch energie
spart entweder aus kostengründen oder
aus verantwortung weil es eben auch
sagen jetzt müssen wir mal alle zusammen
halten weniger energie verbrauchen und
so eine prämie würde da helfen was
übrigens auch gibt es gibt ganz viele
menschen aus meinem bekanntenkreis
sicher aus ihrem bekanntenkreis die
sagen jetzt möchte ich was an meinem
haus machen also für diejenigen die die
möglichkeit haben eine solaranlage das
haus dämmen also da jetzt finanziell
unterstützen da jetzt markt anreize
setzen das hat glaube ich ein
riesenpotenzial das nimmt die leute auch
mit bei der energiewende die
energiewende so lockt ein projekt von
wenigen sein so ein projekt von allen
sein und weil sie noch dieses schöne
stichwort mit den lng terminals
angesprochen haben natürlich das sehen
auch wir das als deutsche umwelthilfe
das sehen auch die umweltverbände man
muss jetzt im herbst was tun und dann
muss da vielleicht auch in
überschaubarem maße lng nach deutschland
importieren aber man darf jetzt
natürlich auch nicht das kind mit dem
bade ausschütten und das kind ist der
klimaschutz das heißt diese
überdimensionierten planungen wieder
teilweise im gespräch sind die die gas
lobbyist versuchte auf kosten der krise
durchzudrücken das geht natürlich nicht
sondern wir müssen das was wir jetzt
machen das muss zeitlich begrenzt sein
das muss von der größenordnung begrenzt
sein mit augenmaß investieren jetzt in
diese übergangstechnologie aber der
große focus müssen da kann ich wieder
nach herrn lindner zitieren das müssen
die freiheits energien das müssen die
erneuerbaren energien seien wird
genügend für
energieeinsparungen deutschland getan
sowohl im privaten wie auch im
unternehmerischen bereich und wenn jetzt
diese gesetzlichen vorschriften
möglicherweise kommen die robert habeck
daran gewöhnt wie kann man das
eigentlich kontrollieren nein es wird
leider nicht genug getan einen der
besten schlechtesten beispiele ist der
stopp der förderung des klima
effizienten bauens wir hatten ja mit der
kfw 40 plus förderung ein wirklich sehr
sehr gutes instrument das auf der einen
seite tatsächlich gebaut wurde aber eben
nach neuesten klimas standards und durch
die ersatzlose streichung dieses
instruments führt es am ende dazu dass
entweder nach alten standards gebaut
werden klammer auf muss denn nicht jede
familie kann sich ohne weiteres
mehrkosten von 25 30 35 tausend euro
auch leisten wir haben bei uns in der
region die ersten rückgaben auch von von
von baugrundstücken
finanzierung werden auf gesagt oder es
wird eben nach alten standard gebaut das
heißt das klima lässt grüßen eine
katastrophe dieser anreiz hat immer
gewirkt dieser anreiz ist gestoppt
worden und das heißt es bringt nichts in
sonntagsreden anzukündigen wir werden
etwas für die energieeffizienz tun und
es dann nicht zu tun beziehungsweise mit
verboten zu arbeiten wir brauchen diese
anreiz und zwar übrigens nicht nur
prämien für den privathaushalt sondern
auch für wirtschaftsbetriebe es gibt
viele mittelständler die sehr stark
schon investiert haben in diesem bereich
absolut zu dass es gibt da sicherlich
noch volumina aber es gibt übrigens in
der wirtschaft einen bestimmten punkt es
gibt betriebe die können sie nicht um 20
oder 30 prozent runter regulieren
sondern wenn wir eine gasmenge lage
kommen sollten dann haben wir das
problem dass es bestimmte produktionen
gibt sie braucht 100 prozent um
durchgängig durchlaufen zu können dh da
gibt es dann auch kein potenzial mehr
und dieses potenzial und deswegen finde
ich es manchmal etwas unseriös wir
müssen sparen ohne frage wir können
sicherlich auch alle selbst mehr sparen
auch das ohne frage
aber es gibt keine belastbaren zahlen es
gibt keine validen daten die
bundesregierung bleibt insoweit die
daten auch schuldig übrigens wie auch
die frage was wird jetzt eigentlich
benötigt wie viel gas bekommen wir aus
katar oder wie auch immer das heißt wir
sind so ein bisschen in grauzonen
entsprechend unterwegs und vor diesem
hintergrund solide instrumente auch
wieder nutzen das heißt nicht um das
ganz deutlich zu machen natürlich ausbau
weiter der erneuerbaren energien wir
sind heute in deutschland bei 40 prozent
und die europawahl sind über 40 jahren
leider sehr viel da wird aber europaweit
ganz weit vorne das darum beneiden uns
andere länder aber es hilft und zur zeit
nicht und das heißt wenn wir eine
brückentechnologie
die brauchen wir zwingend dann brauchen
wir übrigens auch lg und ein lng
terminal ist keine investition für ein
zwei oder drei jahre sondern sie muss
tatsächlich eine gewisse sicherheit auch
haben deswegen gab es ja den
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf auch den
wir auch mit unterstützt haben denn am
ende brauchen wir diese
brückentechnologie und dazu gehört dem
grunde nach auch eine stele viele themen
aber ich finde es mit der kfw ist
tatsächlich ein sehr sehr gutes beispiel
für das was wir brauchen bei der
energieeffizienz weil jahrelang
veraltete standards gefördert wurden das
heißt wir haben wir aufbau steuergelder
in ja auch rein daran gegeben dass
häuser so gebaut wurden dass sie zügig
waren dass sie nicht co2 mindern gebaut
waren und ähnliches und deswegen hat mir
dann auch die finanzierungslücke und ich
bin sehr sehr froh dass wir in zukunft
wirklich adäquates standards fördern
werden ein neues programm
wann kommt die sie haben leider ziemlich
4 milliarden aus dem fenster geworfen
und wir mussten jetzt sind shout meinen
die milliarden gerade für einen neuen
ort möglich ein auto mit rauswerfen 96
milliarden sich wieder aussehen ich habe
sie auch ausreden lassen es wird jetzt
auch ein programm kommen um wirklich den
einbau der wärmepumpen zu forcieren das
sind alles dinge für die es bisher gar
keinen anreiz gab solaranlagen auf den
dächern war super bürokratisch und
deswegen wir haben diese gebäude wenn du
jetzt eingeleitet und natürlich auch mit
dem co2 preis dass es auch bestandteil
dessen den wir auch an die bürgerinnen
bürger wieder zurückgeben würde gerne
jetzt in den letzten sieben minuten doch
einen aspekte und häufiger hier
angesprochen wird ist auch nochmal
ansprechen und habe mir da keiner die
frage sind wenn wir jetzt so viel kohle
luft blasen müssen wenn die
brückentechnologie noch länger bleibt
findet die klimaschutzziele wirklich
erreichbar
2030 raus aus der kohle 2045
klimaneutral also quasi keinerlei
emissionen mehr bei der klima und
stromerzeugung ist das wirklich
erreichbar wenn man einmal denkt dass er
bedenkt dass ja es bei der windkraft
noch vieles offen ist die abstandsregeln
da wird gestritten wie bei den flicks
schuss dann zwei prozent der fläche sind
den wenigsten ländern ausgewiesen im
durchschnitt es gibt widerstand von
bundesländern von bürgerinitiativen bei
den solarmodulen sind wir abhängig von
china in der produktion es gibt
rohstoffmangel es gibt handwerker mangel
um diese ganzen module aufs dach zu
bringen ist das wirklich noch
realistisch wenn die jetzt sagen 2 3
oder 1 2 winter brauchen wir kohle strom
brauchen wir atomstrom um gas noch als
für die wärme energiegewinnung zu haben
ist das realistische in so kurzer zeit
fossile energieträger wirklich
überflüssig zu machen sie immer vorhin
gesagt man muss sie eigentlich diesen
weg noch beschleunigen aber ist das
wirklich realistisch nach dem was ich da
gerade skizziert habe das ist natürlich
nur dann realistisch dass diese muster
für erneuerbare energien jetzt wirklich
gibt das unternehmen tesla das haben sie
ja schon zitiert konnte man hat es ja
geschafft in zwei jahren eine autofabrik
in deutschland zu bauen dieses tempo
wünsche ich mir beim ausbau der
windenergie in schichten ausbau der
sonnenenergie und dazu sind wir bereit
natürlich da muss ganz ganz viel
bürokratisch vereinfacht werden da
müssen die genehmigungsbehörden diese
dinge priorisieren da brauchen wir
einheitliche standards auch beim
artenschutz der ist ja wichtig aber
diese entscheidungen die muss mal
treffen diesen interessenausgleich muss
man treffen kann man aber doch auch
schnell treffen dazu sind wir als
naturschutzverbände auch bereit wir
brauchen jetzt natürlich und davon hängt
wirklich alles ab denn ganz rapiden
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien wir
brauchen perspektivisch 100 erneuerbare
energien dazu gehören speicher dazu
gehört dann auch erneuerbare energie in
form von grünem wasserstoff der daneben
auch als backup dient dann wenn wie herr
professor sind dann sagt der wind nicht
weht die sonne nicht scheint natürlich
gibt es speicherung möglichkeiten für
erneuerbare energien es gibt strom
speichern es gibt wärmespeicher es gibt
die speicherung form in form von
wasserstoff natürlich gibt es so ein
system das ganze muss man europäisch
denken weil jedem wo der winter und vor
allem offshore und da sind die dinge
leider gottes in den letzten 16 jahren
viel zu langsam gegangen deswegen haben
wir jetzt diesen stau und da muss jetzt
der turbo eingelegt werden der professor
sinn wie sehen aus ihrer sicht
realistische klimaschutzziele aus jetzt
wir haben ja jahreszahlen genannt die ja
auch zum teil in politische projekte
eingeflossen sind was wäre für sie ein
realistischer zeitraum
naja also jedenfalls nicht bis 2045 das
sind ja noch 23 jahre sie müssen
bedenken deutschland hat den co2 ausstoß
in den letzten 32 jahren um 40 prozent
reduziert und die restlichen 60 sollen
jetzt in 23 jahren passieren das ist ein
ding der unmöglichkeit
die niedrig hängenden früchte am baum
die sind gepflückt und das ist
insbesondere der effekt des untergangs
der ddr industrie dadurch ist sehr viel
co2 eingespart
worden in deutschland
ähnliches wollen wir ja bitte nicht
nochmal im westen wiederholen mit dem
untergang der west industrie also es ist
schlechterdings unmöglich sagt und
absolut utopisch und aus einer anderen
welt als dieser realen welt zu sagen bis
2045 sind wir in der nähe von null
das
wird sehr schnell zerschellen an der
realität und die folge ist dann dass die
menschen sich abwenden werden sie werden
merken dass das nicht im entferntesten
erreicht wird dass sie verarmen durch
die enormen kosten alternativer energien
und das ist sehr schade weil wir ja
eigentlich doch den weg in die grüne
technologie brauchen wir muss einen
überzeugenden weg finden man muss so
argumentiert wie es auch wie es auch
wirklich funktioniert also ich mag diese
utopie nicht das ist schrecklich ich in
meiner jugend habe ich genug gut open
gesehen und ich denke eigentlich man
sollte froh sein wenn man einen
pragmatischeren ansatz findet über ein
weg der wirklich geht und die deutsche
debatte ist in diesem punkt absolut
ideologisch das ist ja schon kaum mehr
zu begreifen war das ist doch elegante
wir haben hier das klimaschutzgesetz der
großen koalition was sagt 20 45 vom
weltklima neutral sein es gibt den
beschluss des bundesverfassungsgerichts
zum klimaschutz der im grunde dieselbe
aus das sind ja das know how das eine
radikale die größe des
bundesverfassungsgericht dass das ist
ein sehr konservatives gremium ist
trotzdem und technisch ich glaube dass
es ist und technisch und wie 40
anschauen das ist das problem weiter
sind salzgitter ag mit 20 35 thema
neutral sein und unternehmen so heutigen
standort in dieser schönen songs die
viel erneuerbare energien vor ort
produziert werden das war das argument
von north gold an den batterien aus
schweden die deswegen dass
schleswig-holstein gekommen ist die und
nicht nach die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
die realität wenn die musste ich so
einen spieler aber wollten sie auch
offen sein was sie tatsächlich alle
erneuerbaren energien angeht und wenn
wir uns gerade oster paket ansehen
da machen sie schon eine
zweiklassengesellschaft von erneuerbaren
energien auf sie reden über wind und
sonne aber wenn es um das thema
geothermie um das thema biomasse auch
geht aber eben beispielsweise ich nenne
nur die kleinwasserkraftanlagen wo
tatsächlich durch eine deckelung die sie
jetzt einführen das wasser denen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes upgegradet
95 als 90 prozent derjenigen die ihre
modernisiert werden sollten und das soll
zehn prozent der über 7000 akw ja dann
seien sie bitte auch offen und sagen wie
die sachlage ist das heißt das neue bzw
modernisierte anlagen keine förderung
mehr erhalten
und das heißt uns hilft am ende nur eine
tatsächlich technologieoffenheit und
ideologie in einer solchen situation
bringt uns weder kurz noch mittel noch
landes kommen
wir haben es auch 30 sekunden kommt ihr
das war die frage auch der sendung
kommen wir gut durch den winter trotz
allem nein wenn wir den ernst der lage
erkennen und jetzt handeln
dank ja
wenn dann tatsächlich jetzt gemeinsam
technologieoffen erklären ja gut dann
bedanke ich mich die düsseldorfer
setzten
dann bedanke ich mich für diskussion bei
dieser bat um bei gitta connemann bei
das war schon wieder krenner und bei
hans werner sinn liebe zuschauer morgen
in der phoenix runde steigende corona
zahlen zurück zu den maßnahmen so zu den
crooner maßnahmen es folgt jetzt für
nichts der tag mit mayer weber thema
unter anderem der tag der deutschen
industrie in berlin bleiben sie bei uns